do you remember the guy that when Brody
Stephens did this show we talked about
my neighbor in silver like remember the
guy that said he would come to my
apartment go I killed and he didn't kill
so after that podcast was aired he
texted me out of nowhere I haven't
talked to this guy in 12 years bring up
breathe attacks oh yeah and I'm gonna
read it to you and this is so he is now
opening for me in Ontario so this is
what it hey Bobby I want to be honest
with you about my feelings you mentioned
me of your on your podcast I was
surprised you only mentioned my showing
you set VHS is saying that I killed and
then said I really bombed and not put in
me or our interactions on the time frame
of what that was in context that was
easily 15 to 17 years ago I was barely a
few years in the stand-up and you were a
veteran already I thought we had at
least a casual acquaintance friendship
how am i wronged you in some way over
the years please let me know I've barely
seen you in the last many years you're a
famous comedian and I'm an unknown so
you think it's cool to talk to me only
that harshly in a critical way I'm doing
a warm-up set for roast battle Tuesday
March 13th
come on by if you want to see the comedy
Adam got me actually does now
you guys feeling I think that yeah so
then I called attack suit oh my god I'm
sorry and I go you want to open I think
that's and he goes yeah so now he's
gonna open for me and I'm gonna tell you
right now if he's better than George
it's gonna be I'm gonna rub it in
George's face is fair though seven years
ago it's fair what he just said and he's
a nice guy
and I I might have [ __ ] up you wronged
him i wronged him and many people are
wrong on the show mm-hm
okay it's you know you're making a and
I'm gonna make some and we you know what
I'm gonna make some apologies already
right now since we're on the [ __ ]
train men I apologize to John capper
alone oh wow that's a big one no I I you
know I've been reflecting about our
friendship
you know at the end of the day the past
is the past I know he hates me but I
want to make amends I'm sorry for what I
don't know just I'm gonna do it a lot of
yeah I'm just doing it right I want to
make a man I've talked bad about
Christopher Titus because he doesn't
like me but I you know what Christopher
I like you I'm a big fan of your comedy
and let's you know I have no hard
feelings
you can open for Bobby you can know he's
a headliner he's a full-blown headliner
and that's how wars began you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right else do I have beef with
Brooke Shields Brooke Shields broke she
you didn't talk to me when I did that
pilot with you years ago new car smell
the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] about no Brooke sorry
sorry Brooke that's it right mm-hmm
you know so speaking of apologies what
thanks sorry should we get into
[Music]